what I'm really hoping is that there
that's just a show and there's actually
a shadow government that is stable and
that's keeping I know long-term thoughts
I hope that's the case yeah hey let's go
I hope that there is an Illuminati
thinking long term
[Music]
Brazil and China have stricken a trade
deal agreement to ditch the United
States dollar it's terrifying oh no a
bunch of other countries they just did
one with Iran yep yeah a bunch of them
China has overtaken the United States as
Brazil's top training partner back in
uh and now Brazil and trying to have a
reportedly struck they kind of depaked
the dollar bro or in favor of their own
currencies and trade transactions and
Russia too yes sir and yeah so China and
Brazil will carry out trade and
financial transactions directly now
exchanging Yuan for Reese
Aries
I don't know or vice versa rather than
first converting their currencies for
the US dollar which is what they did
before again the world's Reserve
currency 60 of the world's reserves in
currency are US Dollars which means like
that is the biggest
thing that you trade against right that
has the most liquidity I heard uh
Indonesia
Saudi Arabia really yeah Iran yeah Iran
yeah Iraq but and it's like damn I think
it's like more than 40 of the world so
it's about to get more than half and
then yeah oh that's bad is Brazil's
largest trading partner a country for
more than a fifth of All Imports
followed by the United States so even
though this was the case
they were still trading with US Dollars
damn that's crazy China's also Brazil's
largest export Market according
accounted for more than a third of all
exports China overtook the United States
as a Brazil's top trading partner back
in 2009 China's everyone's a trading
partner though because everything's
manufactured in China yeah and our poor
relationships with China with like
shipping Logistics manufacturing
operations like that's only gonna like
yeah [__] us up even way more because
they got the power even we would rely on
them for a bunch of [__] you know oh
yeah dude dang this yeah it's kind of
scary the super power shift happening
right before our eyes
and I don't know I mean I like America
and this is my home sometimes I go man
Trump was actually pretty cool he kept
everything cool everyone respected him I
mean maybe he had a loud mouth and he
said crazy [__] but people are like oh
don't [__] with that guy but it honestly
worked in our favor that he was pissing
off America more than he was pissing off
China
I thought he pissed off China by doing
all those trade deals like well they
they did a deal
like it was a deal but I thought the
deals was to benefit America better well
yeah we're trying to sign on on their
side too they're like okay oh you see
like but now we're not talking now
they're all doing those deals without
America yeah Xi Jinping and
just just met signed like 14 [__]
docs it's like no one's scared of who we
got now so they're all doing deals
behind our back and then also it also
seems like North Korea don't give a [__]
about us whereas before I feel like
North Korea I respect America and then
our response is what like let's build
some more like uh military bases in the
Philippines in order to get ready for a
threat like you know what I'm saying
yeah let's add um turkey let's add all
these crystals to Nato let's or turkey
just ratified
um I can't remember who to Nato but like
they're they're basically just doubling
down on what they're doing that's why it
made more sense when people were mad at
Trump rather than China was mad at
America okay I'll take it kind of
China's exports and imports with Russia
surged a double digit Pace back in
January February from a year earlier
double digit
that just goes to show the sanctions
that have happened against Russia were
exploited right like China's like hey uh
we can help you out because nobody wants
to do Commerce with you we will we're
being glossed over you know what's crazy
is some people don't understand
geopolitical things so much that they
don't see this as a threat at all no big
picture just a big deal
I mean why are you so racist with the
screws to Russia for 5 500 upvotes on
Reddit that through sanctions sanctions
against Russia it's like yeah dude you
don't know the ramifications of those
things like do you not understand even
if like there's no all-out war right
even if that if we aren't the superpower
say [__] goodbye to your luxuries and
I'm talking about like just normal
American life is already living like
luxury yeah for sure like say [__]
goodbye like imagine a loaf of bread is
twenty dollars now a bottle of water is
like 15 bucks
we've gotten [__] recently again we
called that during the covet all the
inflation that was going on we were
calling that back then we were like yo
dude hold your dollars because it's
about to get real but then everyone's
like there's a bunch of conspiracy [__]
and all this stuff yeah guess what
happened dude your dollar got inflated
and your purchasing power got [__]
wrecked yeah go figure and Bitcoin surge
because people are losing faith in it
you know what I'm saying like and and
you're talking about like all these like
major central banks in different areas
[__] purchasing gold you know what I
mean because like there's talk about
that so so again you know I and I was I
was watching this video from who is it
from Jazz Street minority mindset
earlier this morning talking about like
again there's just articles article
after article you're just seeing this
trend this flow of different currency a
different uh and central banks from
those different nations purchasing [__]
tons of gold because in this potential
new world order that doesn't rely on the
uh US dollar as a reserve currency
they're gonna want a currency that is
actually backed by gold so that's why
banks are starting to purchase golds in
masses again it's not guaranteed it's
nothing's like formally and officially
signed that this is guaranteed going to
be a new world currency but with the
distrust in the dollar and thinking
about moving and migrating to some sort
of other currency cbdc yeah there's
still going to be some concept of like
what is that being backed by because
just as jaspered was saying right now
the US dollar since like the 70s hasn't
been backed by gold so it's been backed
by trust but it's been backed by the
promise that the U.S economy is always
going to be at the top the US military
is always going to be the top capitalism
through the U.S standing power is always
going to be at the top but the second we
lose that concept of a promise to the
rest of the global economy like say
right now like right now it's like who
are they why would they trust the dollar
that's it's going going to almost like a
bank run you know what I mean it's going
to inflate the the the the our entire
economic currency and then it's going to
put trust in something else everybody's
going to need to fortify their trust in
something else and the only thing they
can do is something like gold
something's that has an actual standard
of currency that makes sense you know so
people can put trust behind it because
you can't trust the US dollar anymore
and that's reasonable for us let's go or
digital gold yeah g pack cheap what's
digital well Bitcoin Bitcoin gpxg is
like crypto that you know basically
similar to tether you know tether yeah
usdt they they're basically gpxg is
basically saying hey for everyone you
know
um dollar of gpxg we generate we have a
backing in Gold like percentage-wise can
that ever get d-pegged like dude we just
don't know right like tether yeah so
tethers like their Founders are a
company called bitfinex and they're like
a group that basically says for every
one dollar of tether regenerate
um we are backing it in a vault in Peru
they've never been successfully audited
they hire a bunch of friendly Auditors
we don't know anything about it and
again I don't know that they definitely
don't have it I just don't know so it's
impossible to speculate is that trust is
that trust like what we have in the US
dollar is there gold in Fort Knox we
don't [__] know China's biggest
Achilles heel is apparently it's China
because they're so massive
um they spend a lot more time and energy
keeping their own like States and stuff
in check with basically like corruption
is pretty rampant and on top of that
because it's a part of their political
culture and on top of that like
infighting so because of that and how
many
um what do you call it like of their top
leaders they have somewhat of a brain
drain where they want to go to Western
countries right or they'll invest uh
some type of Safeguard there and then
they will send their kids and then they
retire there because they don't want to
be in China so
if that continues then that they could
implode on themselves but we don't know
yet this Chinese billionaire came out
and he was just like saying like
um he got a political Asylum or whatever
he was whistleblowing and he was just
saying like America doesn't even know
what they're dealing with because China
has the ability to plan a hundred years
in advance it's one political party it's
one group it's one crony there they
don't have political opponents versus in
the U.S there's all these small caps
fighting for power as Xi Jinping just
won a third election which is like
literally the first time in however long
Generations that the same thing like
America they used to be like oh your
president can only like have two terms
and they just Nix that whole thing to
basically in in unanimous decisions vote
this guy back into a third term
basically eradicating that law saying
that he could basically run China and
the CCP for the rest of his life so
they've gone kind of back one group one
CEO
yeah and if you don't have to keep
campaigning like think of all the plans
he could make especially in a stop to
campaign yeah and in their economy
um it's it's government owned a lot of
the businesses they have a stake in it
and if they wanted to they'll just take
it yeah so like every every company that
does extremely well what ends up
happening is they get a stake in it or
they take it over completely or if they
rescue like remember that big
um real estate company that got shut
down because they over leveraged the one
during the pandemic yeah in China we
thought that it was good
Evergreen Evergreen Evergreen apparently
that's like a thing out there where like
they let companies over leverage get big
get crazy right and then
um they just wait for them to fail and
then the government comes in and goes oh
you need a bailout well it's our company
now every time we're about to get
wrecked by that by the way everyone
thought it was over because of that we
actually spiked hard after yeah and then
the real estate went crazy but I just
think they have advantages that we don't
so like in the US because our sometimes
our democracy works against us right
like in a way where if we're competing
with a group that doesn't have to so
there's no term limits
lifetime appointments if you're
comparing countries to countries I know
what you're saying the big picture is
these guys don't have to why do you
compete so that's the scary part yeah we
have to vote we have to campaign we
don't have a dictator but shouldn't it
be tilted towards what the public wants
not that that ever happens in my opinion
but it's gonna be at least intent yeah
based I mean yeah we're supposed to but
with all this infighting and people just
spending time like campaigning
are they thinking about the big picture
I don't know I think they are because
they just selected like a 95 year old
guy
by a lot of votes what I'm really hoping
is that there that's just a show and
there's actually a shadow government
that is stable and that's keeping I know
long-term thoughts I hope that's the
case yeah hey let's go I hope that there
is an Illuminati thinking long term yeah
yeah there's gotta be gonna be you know
why because the concept of even the cvdc
like the Central Bank digital currency
this new concept of a digital currency
that's Run by One Central organization
that is not even tied specifically to a
singular nation is no different than the
dollar let's [__]
go who issues the dollar Anthony
the Illuminati it's close Federal
Reserve
the Illuminati yeah exactly it's the
same [__] who oh is the Federal Reserve
govern our government no
they're an independent body
the President appoints their leader sure
but we we have no control over them
other than yeah we appoint that guy
creepy it's kind of [__] up I don't
even know what the Federal Reserve is
dude I just hear it hey Bart you want to
audit them you can't people have been
trying to do it for 25. the private bank
you can't do it it's the iron bank
which is why the idea of even like
bailing out Banks or like you know like
Silicon Valley like all those things
tanking like and then that being almost
like this again conspiracy theorist mind
like leading towards like oh it makes a
lot of sense for a central bank digital
currency to be the thing that like runs
everything versus like these like
individually trusted like things you
know what I mean it all is kind of
leading towards this of course we should
trust in the central figure that has all
the the control and stuff you know we
should submit our control we should
submit our trust towards this Central
currency anywhere else anywhere else we
send troops we will literally take over
your reserves ourselves to make sure
you're playing ball with us
Federal Reserve is based in the United
States
we don't send troops we don't we don't
control them
fascinating fascinating good word that's
optimistic right this bummed me out
brought to you by Raytheon
[Music]